hey guys this is andrew from
sendingcensus.com so i've been working
as a professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong and right now
guys i'm doing youtube videos
because i want to pass the knowledge i
want to show you guys how portrayal is
actually working
what kind of tools we're using what is
working what is not and the most
important thing
how to use those tools so if you want to
know about all the stuff and how to make
money on the markets you are in the
right place
so today i want to make an update on skt
tenger
let's get into it
[Music]
so first let's have a look at the chart
quickly so i'm on a daily time frame and
you can see that we had some crazy moves
here on the 4th of march so we're going
to try to understand what happened here
and what is the right thing to do
so here i have the volume uh the volume
is the bars that you can have
like that you can see here and you can
see that basically
skt has never traded as many shares as
it did on the 4th of march in its
entire life so
this is very interesting to notice
now if i go on yahoo finance and i try
to check the news the first thing i'm
going to find is stuff like this
take tango factory outlet shares i'd buy
wall street bets
jump then retreat so basically you have
a lot of
momentum coming from reddit and
you can see that basically here tenger
was the number one training stock in the
wall street bed community
and you can also find that here tanger
factory was the number one trading
ticker on yahoo finance so it's
basically
something that people are looking for
and
you had some good uh fourth quarter
results that have been published
that were much better than last year
like the
the first three quarters you had like 90
percent of increase
in the people that were visiting the
shops and stuff like this so it's kind
of good but still guys a bit
of a cloud in the sky on skt is that the
company wants to sell as much as 215
250 million dollars worth of shares
so basically this is called a share
offering they want to raise money
through equity
and they are going to basically emit
shares and dilute
the current investors so if in this
very strong move up that we had here so
basically the market
took around you know 25
30 percent in in a matter of few hours
and then
got uh massively uh sold so i'm
wondering who was selling here
was it hedge funds or was it actually
the company that was emitting shares
good question because if it's the
company that was emitting shares
they're going to be done very soon you
know so this is
kind of good so i'm going to go back to
technicals but first i want to have a
luch
uh with you guys on uh at the short
interest
so i go on market watch and i just tap
type
skt and you can find here the total
number of shares that were sold
with the date it was published so the
26th of february so this is fresh data
and you have 32 percent of short
interest you can protect this data with
market bid same thing you type
skt and you go here on short interest
and you can see that
here it's 32 so this data is correct you
have the same data on market watch as
you do on market bits
and i'm working as a professional trader
so i have bloomberg i'm not allowed
to uh show you guys here bloomberg data
but i check it as well and if
if i see that uh you know there is a big
difference then i know that probably
bloomberg is right
and i'm gonna let you know guys as i did
for amc
and for gamestop but here the data is
correct and is the same as we
have on bloomberg so 32 it's a lot guys
so short squeeze is likely to happen
another interesting thing you can check
what is the institutional ownership so
what are the big clients doing
and they are they were selling in 2020
you know see here they were selling like
uh 800 million
in the second quarter of 2020 and 21
they are rather quiet they are waiting
now let's go back to technicals guys i
did a video on skt
i think it was around here so one month
ago
and we were having so i'm gonna explain
to you guys what are those lines
but we were having here the first
breakout and i was telling you
don't buy it like you know uh like i
don't know at 15
but buy it at 12 i was actually saying
1180
so here you know i would like uh have
been executed at the staff
and guys what happened actually so i
connected
here the two recent highs so you can see
that we have a downtrend
that is divided into you have this
downtrend here and here suddenly
it went much lower so here you have
another downtrend all right you can hear
do a third one and to capture as well
this breakout but this was like
you know kind of more steep here we have
something easier to play
so i was saying that here if you connect
i always connect to two or three
most recent highs in the downtrend so
one two three here
and then you can see that you wait for
the breakout you wait for two candles to
trade above
and then you buy the retest so here we
have like one breakout retest here
then the real breakout and the real
re-test so here i was a buyer around 12
and with the stop loss here around 11
let's say
so i gave you this trade yes for those
who have watched this video you heard
this before it happened
and here guys i'm telling you the same
thing so i'm pretty sure so this is the
exact same situation this is
uh the perfect situation here it's even
better because the volume is even higher
and everybody's talking about the stuff
and they have good
like better results so everything is
actually going in the right direction
and here once again guys we have the
breakout one two
small re-test the big breakout and the
big retest
so guys i give you one or two days
maximum
to buy the stuff guys so you can put a
stop loss once again guys if you like to
check with stop-loss i like to do this
because
you know i think it's more safe we have
this
support level that is here this is the
downward sloping trend line that we have
of the uh whole move down
and you can buy it so at 16 17 whatever
and you can take profits actually guys
uh
at 42 because if a short switch happens
and it's likely to happen because we
have a big short interest 32
then this stuff can go massively higher
and take 150
so you can lose 15 20 and make 150 so
it's a 1 to 10 risk reboot ratio
it's very good yeah and one more thing i
wanted to say here you have this upward
sloping trend line that is just
connected to two recent lows
and this is acting as support as well so
here we have a double signal guys
which with a very a strong increase
in the volume uh traded so this is uh
the perfect situation guys i'm giving
you this one
and you do whatever you want but i'm a
very strong buyer
here all right guys that's it for me i
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did please don't forget to click
on the sub like and bell button so
you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys